the rating to be able to build something is the
collaboration with hubble west
itineris collaborated management of the autonomics
enjoy the night live in my own voices in
spain myself in the air
from webmail cinema and light in space and
space blue night live'
and it's how we do in our  life the
things that we go one way and
end up somewhere else but in the end it is
a surprise that if the development
of the age limit journey you had it
then but it makes sense already when the
magazines have been wound and filmax the
moment more than the plot  more than the
stooges more than dayton moore it was
the director's decision
the director lived analize de camera
movement of references of the
thai vittorio of the two
decisions solution pixels
people only the directors guild achievements
[Music]
we made of stars
because we wanted  to be an artist
nations annual investment in
metaphysics survey new defense of
exploring the fluid of an idol of the
imagination explore presents
prod  ucciones error build and physical
calling the complete
or not
willis
the intellectual web
suárez
i am that's what is not an 2030
and robert stephens in the field of the
process there is something is the collaboration carried
out the collaborators action of the
autonomous
enjoy the night and day that  my own
voices in spain is the fis that tyler
moore
collaboration several nightclubs and lips
[Música]
the revelation of secrets
link son they had wiiware project in
waters the end of creation of the creation would not be
understood I am sweet in
the thousand 516 you are  different from those that
have to be facebook in his studio
observe is the adventure observable
resilience endurance revenge in sol
forni what was very important waters of
spiritual peace dimension
in commitments physical xtreem experience
as this guy winter bears whale rider is
possible to transform
interior son emotions  shriver web
the view meeting point what really makes
somebody survive
anderson james
inditex
beris staff
so de people
[Music]
yes
uruguay
cinema
space flight facebook bright light
[Music]
the end is extremely important as
how that is built you think of the
end first or from the beginning as
you go with as the process not in my
case the mouth  there are different ways of
approaching it for different people for
me personally I could tell you that I
almost always start on a journey that does not
have a predestined ending
in fact in my point of view it
would be very boring for me to know where I am going
because then it would be nothing more  job
of building something with a known purpose
in the place of a traveler you
become a tourist and I think you have to take
a trip a one-way ticket to buy
a one-way ticket it is more exciting
not knowing when you are going to return with whom
you are going to  sleep in what or what
cities are the people who know the adventures going to take you to
I think having
confidence is why I think you do
have to have it is a purpose is there is a
I believe in that seed, I believe in
encoding the final dna as the
reason the reason those
seeds the peach seed will give a peach but
I think that the end must not be
predictable because it is already predictable and
as a creator if you do  you know it's still
boring
even if it's surprising but it says
somehow the audience is going to feel it
predictable
but it's also true that an end almost
always when they are good they are
inevitable that is to say the sum of the
decisions of the things of a character
has to happen and  it makes sense but you
never saw it coming and it's how we make
our lives things we go one
way and end up somewhere else but in the
end it's a surprise that the
development of the trip gives you and
you didn't even have it yourself but it already makes sense when
check it if this is
the bieber industrial index and shows or
one day before guard rock the next day
of are you doing words and end astray
typical
5 evolution is space river
breyer explore d  e carter in everything
in exploring dramatic
character objectives ones unity if there is not a
lover ways to what she wants I dance
different action see them on youtube
demand new sound and found the center of
bolivia we chose it soon city
baldwin santander 19 respect list
exact understand  works in
medical looks with a trajectory of various
aspects in the new line and one of the rhythm
life
skylanders deadly false squeeze the
words in one or two shots thinking and
novelty of being 12 eggs from hunan
where it is so cool two words and
media brotherhoods repeat why  i want
to say that they will arnett teachers
one
confidence in the benefit a glove
only one that will not be records
a train to define
the
energy glove or improvisation at the
present moment in combat a knife in
may be that way' disguise looks
combination evolution of the lucid type in
two programs of duty singular intellectual point
pons
efe
of decisions
with its decision without ac  marxist
ción bye bye bye bye blondie
[Music]
said
with the vision of god a because it's
true sometimes
yes we design ney tv absolute
indifference campo in the forest
stronguista tacvba de berg new start
and then we know we ride straight son
audio elements  not only from the
mosquitoes investment of forces is
different from that of abertis angel and you
are not going to see the one from hollywood to
biased hannover sabines landsbergis who is
thirsty and there are no differences
zinc rate the gods are 30 and it is with what
their parts are retained  from clifford sample
1 river and away comes your hand of
energies talent show and character farm
from landscapes wood
the word and no way we were not only to
very low from this orientation from winter
angel from facebook the winter in itinere
from frank way de pendín  what we need
order change see and I will not unsay
with the buffalo man and them
matter
i
mercy
in this meeting way fragment the way to
standard life in the way the people is
just yo te  ngo some denounce in the
jungle
because the war is willing and survival
is the beatles taiwan of tivo textiles
I leave f1
[Music]